今天要聊一個很有意思的案例。一家叫做 Duqu 的公司，他們做的事情其實很簡單，就是幫企業解決「錢被卡在未付款發票裡」的問題。
解決這問題不難啊，傳統金融業不是就有應收帳款融資、或是票貼這種服務嗎？這有什麼特別的？
喔，特別就在這裡。Duqu 的創辦人 Maas de Goede 就說了，現在什麼事情都能即時辦理，但錢卻可能要等上好幾個禮拜才能入帳，這跟現在企業營運的速度完全不搭。所以他們把這個「快」做到了極致。
怎麼說「極致」？銀行那些服務也很努力在縮短時間啊。
他們的關鍵點在於，結合 AI 自動化了 95% 的信用評估流程。這點在原文有提到，Curiosity 的 Herman Kienhuis 說，傳統上小額信貸申請的評估和處理成本很高，但 Duqu 的 AI 引擎就能讓這些小額申請也能有利可圖。
等等，95% 的評估流程都靠 AI？這樣會不會風險太高？萬一判斷錯誤，錢收不回來怎麼辦？這模式能撐多久？
這點其實是他們的核心競爭力。根據原文，Duqu 建立這套 AI 引擎已經一年半了。而且它不只自己用，還能以「白牌解決方案」的形式，提供給銀行、貸款機構使用，讓這些傳統業者也能照自己的信用政策自動評估。
我猜啦，傳統金融業很難做到這麼快速，是因為他們的人力成本、流程都太僵化了。這家 Duqu 就是抓住了這個痛點，用科技降本增效。
沒錯。他們號稱在發票開立後，企業就能立刻獲得資金。錢在 24 小時內就能轉入，甚至很多時候一小時內就搞定。這對很多急需周轉的企業來說，真的很有吸引力。
聽起來跟應收帳款買賣，也就是所謂的「應收帳款承購」有點像，但又有點不一樣。
對，原文有特別強調，Duqu 的模式不是讓企業把發票賣掉，企業仍然保有跟客戶的關係。他們是提供一個「短期墊款」，有點像預支，企業只在真正用到這筆墊款時才付費。而且沒有最低或最高金額的限制。
沒有最低或最高金額限制，這點很有意思。傳統銀行對小額的貸款，審核成本高，常常不願意做。Duqu 靠 AI 就能處理這些，確實是傳統金融難以企及的服務。
所以如果我是個小店老闆，常常要等客戶月結，錢就卡住了。我就可以把未收的發票透過 Duqu 平台，提早拿到錢來買貨、付員工薪水，甚至做行銷，不用因為等待而延誤。
這點我信了，因為原文有提到具體數字，光在西歐，就有近一半（47%）的 B2B 發票逾期。這代表很多企業的錢都被卡住。Duqu 這種快速周轉的服務，確實解決了燃眉之急。
對啊，換個角度想，如果我們把這個概念帶入到一般上班族的生活或工作，其實也有啟發。
怎麼說呢？上班族哪來什麼應收帳款？
比方說，你可能有個案子做到一半，需要某個資源或預算才能推進，但流程很慢，錢還沒到位。如果能有個像 Duqu 這樣的「微型即時加速器」，讓你先拿到所需的「資源」，專案就能跑得更快。
你的意思是，把這種「快速審批、即時到位」的思維，應用在工作流程上？減少等待和卡關，讓資源可以更彈性地流動。
對，就是這個意思。它提醒我們，很多時候不是沒資源，而是資源流動慢。把 AI 和平台化思維帶入，能讓低效能的流程變得高效率。
看來 Duqu 不只解決了企業的現金流問題，也給我們提了一個問題：我們的日常工作流程裡，是不是也有很多「未付款發票」？這些卡住的流程，我們有沒有辦法用新的方法去「解鎖」？
沒錯。這個案例好像也提醒了我們，那些看似理所當然的「慢」，是不是其實有機會透過科技被重新定義。